you can't be écouter aujourd'hui se
trouve pour l'avant dernier épisode d'un
étudiant je suis super excitée parce que
l'épisode d'avant était juste [ __ ] de
riches en émotions c'est parti pour la
suite mais avant le précédent de hunted
d'entre vous l'adorez aaa
ça vous a plu de terroriser toutes ces
émotions que mes soeurs ont dû ressentir
il ya un an
et devinez quoi bon temps réel
non non non non non parce qu'elles sont
mortes
jessica hay morte [ __ ] quoi entendu
jessica est morte et tu vas payer pour
ça qu pas d'art sans parler de joyce
mike je me souviens pas avoir tué [ __ ]
[ __ ]
révélation au sel ça je sens qu'on va
savoir qui est ce mec là bizarrement un
[ __ ] j'ai hâte j'ai hadjadj est alors
est-ce que emilie s'en sortent
this is the great day to day messieurs
genre il va pas la si jolie 10
non non ça soit on réduit les gentils ya
des [ __ ] de civilisés et des [ __ ]
zombies il m'a protégé c'est quoi ce
bordel tonga à des pressions du mec
ouah il ya comme ça qu'est ce qu'elle en
train de chéquier c'est des flames et
suppose like des sionneau
ok allez on y va allez on y va y aller
on a plein de courage mais courageux on
sait que josh n'est pas le ballon mais
leurs bêtes c'est ni le mec qu'on
pensait que lancelot mais qu'on pensait
qu'avec soit en somme il a pas l'air
méchant lui en fait il est il est juste
en train de chasser du piano dont be
pour le faire cuire au four il adore
cette viande et ils nous arrêtent et en
plus il nous a aidé le mec je suis
choqué quel retournement de situation
c'est exceptionnel tous types pas alors
le mot sur les toulousains censure
éventuellement voilà alors ça c'est quoi
tout ça en fait ça appartient ce mec là
quand même et comme celle où billy budd
équipe d explose mine du nord-ouest
alberta salut billy c'était génial n'est
ce pas passer mon boss tu viens à
calgary l'on est alors on malade mais
hélas on est dans les délais fameuse
mine où il y avait un éboulement il est
23 morts peut-être que lui c'est un gars
qui n'est dans les mines avant mine de
blackwood cet art il amène à la salle
ont subi un effondrement majeur bah
voilà c'est ce qu'on avait vu à la
morgue sur les notes
[ __ ] c'est ouf à l'asile pardon à léon
d'essence ce truc à l'aider sans talent
et vilaine balafre au genou ça doit
piquer ya des [ __ ] de son billet mon
gars c'est dingue mais tout ça sort
bordel là y'a un truc c'est un totem
je reconnais ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a
pas le mien voilà c'est tout m de quoi
attention pas de mort ou danger ce
serait vraiment agréable
totem de choses ok je n'ai rien compris
à ce totem
j'ai juste vu avec un gun qui fait comme
taiwo bizarre alors on a tiré sur quoi
sur des grosses pierres 1 qu'est ce qui
est à se faufiler au c'est bon ça oh la
la
mascherano ya 6 e
j'ai hâte et j'ai hâte et non c'est bon
c'est bon ça passe au [ __ ] quitter au
plus vite et aller prendre l'huître à ce
point les traces au mec c'est comme
sauter les clients opèrent à la droite à
la gauche
j'en sais rien mais je joue quelle
erreur qui a débord [ __ ] aller ça
marche ça marche ça marche ça marche
go go go adios à les mines ça va aller
ça va aller
t'inquiète pas ces petits gollum ils
sont là ils cherchent à nos tu donnes
tabac et que ça passe ça passe
je bouge pas put acheter malin dans la
merde où je passe je bouge pas dans la
poche mais la vache et messieurs ça
bordel quand je marche un peu marre
d'aller vers non non non non on remonte
un peu à ça va aller babel on s'en est
sorti mon gars ont bien joué bien c'est
ça la vue vous avez vu la vie des stades
de vision thermique de merde c'est ses
goûts de merde qu'ils ont imputés à
miley la chaire est là elle sans frais
leur propre et dire tout le groupe
elle est belle souhaite le faire olala
amy tu gères oh [ __ ] d'accoucher
j'adore j'adore allant jusqu'à céder à
ce casse
je compare ce concept alors que là mais
on se casse s'estompe la sauter sauter
ouais
bah jockey second tapis à les mini tu
peux faire glisse pakistan glisse pas
qu'ils se parlent tout va bien se passer
[ __ ] tempête en plus de l'or c'est la
merde
tirez dessus tirer dessus
je pourrais tu me raviser plates-bandes
afro k oui [ __ ] merde oui aller comme
ça a lancé en six ans et rémi lyon cyr
tha allez ça va cesser c'est la nana la
bonne boudreau elles meurent à cause de
ses maux elle prend mediashare allez tu
t'en sors j'ai confiance en toi
s'il te plaît voila voila on sait pas
trop ce moment mais ça va aller allez
billy ok to book en sueur était en train
de courir elle en train de sortir d'un
jour des autres allez je préfère la
confiance est pas vrai
elle rejoint les autres pour leur dire
merde croire pour lui
[Musique]
le malade a paniqué mais si complètement
cookies et ligoté josh ailleurs ils ont
pu les côtés dans le manoir la chaise
n'aurait rien fait soupe d'huile 1 kg et
tout va bien perdu attend un monstre
perdu vase explique leur explique les
raisons sont là j'ai dit que j'ai suivi
n'avaient rien d'humain perdu que s'est
il passé
elles expliquent nos cheveux je m'en
fous de match tout expliquer à tout le
monde c'est certes vous expliquer la
tour est tombée
voilà il ya des mines sous nos pieds des
galeries partout et c'est là qu'on a
atterri il ya un troisième macaron
d'habitude tu as qui a coupé le câble de
l'atome il est noir
ça peut être quelque chose de triste
truc à droite
j'ai trouvé la tête de oui je laisse
sérieuse j'écoute et non dans la tour il
y avait une radio et j'ai réussi à
contacter quelqu'un mais c'est la
plateau est tombé tu as réussi il ya les
sélections du matin on essaie de le
découvrir
et puis il ya ce monstre qui la
poursuivait elle a vraiment l air bien
emilie m
il ya vraiment sûrs je suis sûr qu'à
vraiment hein tu as apporté ni josh ses
jeans aux macaques sont en flammes
c'est pas de chef c'est le troisième est
qu'on a vu dans l'asile déçu mais je
sais pas si je te couvre rocha courage
qui top moyens annoncés low-tech celle
où la ces [ __ ] blue a demandé deux
mois le flingue ou suggérés je vais
ouvrir la porte à deux mâles flingue
dommage mais je vais le faire la vache
on ouvre la porte là prenons maintenant
tout le monde pascal mais bon mettez
vous tous ici aller vite
je vais vous expliquer ce que je suis là
haut il faut que je vous dise cela quoi
vous avez à faire sur cette montagne
donc lui il est mal an j'ai pas dû
revenir ici c'est de la folie après ce
qui s'est passé l'an dernier
vous voulez dire avec canal baisse vous
n'êtes pas censé être au courant de ça
si vous n'êtes pas responsable vous
baisser d'un ton tout de suite je vienne
à la trop que les gamins viennent
grimper comme ça sur ma montagne votre
montagne je suis sûr que les washington
serait super content d'entendre océan
washington
cette montagne ne m'appartient pas c'est
vrai nom se venger mais elle n'est pas
non plus au washington cette montagne
appartient owen qui courent c'est
laisser les invertis qu'il y à une
malédiction
lui qui sévit dans ces montagnes
si n'importe quel être humain recours au
cannibalisme dans ces bois alors
l'esprit du wendigo sera libéré
non mr au hall des flashbacks la députée
de manigod vous allez devoir trouver un
lieu sûr à gaza pour elles air hockey
descendez tous maintenant et attendez
quoi pourquoi
jusqu'à quand jusqu'à l'aube les gars je
suis parti en laissant de change quand
j'ai entendu crier aux noisettes ou la
laisser dans la cabane
alors ton ami es déjà mort non c'est
impossible
hobbes on est avec lui tout peut se
passer très vite sur cette montagne
oh non je m'en fous je retourne le
chercher bon je viens avec toi j'ai pas
besoin de votre aide et elle est seule
avec toi je suis sur tes fesses ça
suffit c'est toi oh la la zaza pas volé
genre si lui y meurt on est foutu on est
out of the game on les morts
fais attention à iasi qu'il va dire fais
attention à christmas qui s'aiment
autsai et visions of the love on se
revoit vite
[ __ ] christ eu à prendre cher [ __ ]
créé 100 restaurants visités point vous
êtes l'expert ces trucs que l'amoureux
les justes ascension j'essuie mois de
prêt
je te suis monsieur le vilain je suis
avec toi gonfler leur politique turque
comme une carapace
oh la la nique à boucler le type de
cannes pas les balles mais craignent que
le feu quoi d'accord faut les brûler
ensuite tiré super bien c'est sur les
mouvements leur champion ou pas bougé du
coquet
on a regardé on est arrivé et il est
plus là [ __ ] mais dans le dense dans
la merde as josh way que mon ami ne
bouge mais merde merde au cou merde j'ai
pus tard mais les tissus couture les
femmes où on a découvert des fossiles
bon
au jeu de tir et dans le réservoir je
suis con tu appelles l'explosion ils
n'auraient pas suivi
[ __ ] je suis dans la merde oh non j'ai
bougé tout et mahfoud butin dégage
saloperie giguère avec gilet pare-balles
naturel tu as cru tu me faisait peur
dégage
[Applaudissements]
vous ne détestez vous me détestez j'ai
raté le tir à droite monsieur voir et
[ __ ] [ __ ] tu es moi non vous êtes
invités à acheter
c'est pas [ __ ] j'ai envie de baisser
les bras
reste avec moi je
les gones et décore ta gueule de merde
non mais c'est prendre
ah non c'était dur gens puissent qui
traîne sa griffe
[ __ ] c'est pas bon la cua comment ça
il est mort de couper nom et n'a pas il
est adoré je suis désolé ashley et pour
le vieux alors aucune trace je crois il
doit être moi aussi
hoyé oh [ __ ] oui c'est vraiment pas
d'autres bornes ont tourné sur qu'est ce
que tu cherches
oui une autre sortie mike je crois pas
que ce soit une bonne idée on devrait
rester ici et ne pas bouger jusqu'à
l'aube on est en sécurité ici bord ouais
la ligne comme un cadeau avec un petit
regret pour moi cette chose viennent
nous décider le matin de noël des gens
vont venir le chercher mais tu m'as tu
en voilà t'as pas l'air convaincu
c'est comme ça que ça va se passer à
emilie va j'espère va rester ici
moi je me casse mike ya pas de culture
le téléphérique josh micky doit à la pop
& simmons kiss ass
encore un de ces retours super génial
non même si cette saloperie en et josh
alors on est dans la merde
à tangi seul accès possible qu'est ce
qui est possible à temps qu'il joue
habilement
je vais chercher cette clé direct dans
la chambre de cette bestiole et après je
ne sors tous deux être moins arrête
arrête arrête tu vas mourir arrête top
tu sais quoi faire
oui non personne par compris c'est
dangereux d'or merci revenir merci merci
non non non tu as si j'avais pas fait de
bruit avec chris si j'avais pas foiré
mon tir derrière et tout [ __ ] les deux
ils seraient encore en vie quoi ok là on
lit le journal du mec alors les wendy
gonnet à cause du cannibalisme lorsqu'un
humain est infâme et d'espérer piger sur
la montagne dans les tempêtes hivernales
lorsqu'il n'a rien mangé depuis des
jours l'esprit de wengo prendra
possession de lui à une tribu levé
autrefois dans ces montagnes l'écrit
leur chemin de raconte l'histoire d'une
immense créature née dans la glace la
tribu respecter la montagne tous les
éléments ci guinée ah ouais moyens c'est
chaud ça dit que comme les wendy go on
mettait à partir d'humains
lorsqu ils nous chassent ils savent très
bien comment imiter leurs proies en les
[ __ ]
je les ai contenu j'ai utilisé des
pièges pour les attraper le feu pour les
enfermer avaler les pièges à loup que ah
c'était ça c'était ça le piège qui ces
primates dans l'asile vous vous souvenez
en fait on s'est pris un piège de wendy
gros pet shop
olala les légendes qui affirme que loin
des eaux peut infecter un homme en le
mordant mais [ __ ] j'ai été mordu mais
je me suis pas transformer le seul moyen
est de manger la chair de quelqu'un
d'autre et il n'y a pas d'autre moyen
auquel il faut surtout pas avoir l'
envie de manger son pote bois guillaume
et babette stern
merde par verte on doit rejoindre mike
tout de suite
l'erreur de l'année en le retour du
petit mec ça y est tu m'écoutes et des
gens sont morts à cause de vous je ne
sais pas ce qu'il ya de pire
blanchet une série d'événements
résultant la mort de quelqu'un à ses
tourments en fait et on monte de ouf
comme l'année dernière ben quand vous
avez laissé mourir vos soeurs avaient
rien fait moi secourisme c'est au mont
paralysée par votre peur égoïste
alors que le danger était bien réel taux
tourne autour de votre poche vous êtes
si égoïstes
[ __ ] vous donne même le mot shoah et
le ban des choix pourquoi leur faire du
mal
oui dû acheter nous pourquoi t'as vu
faire ça ils m'ont fait du mal je n'ai
fait de mal à personne
bah c'est vrai que ses potes ils ont
déconné sur le coup d'après lui il était
bourré sur une table donc il peut pas
apprécié qu logiquement il les a défoncé
donc on va dire et m'ont fait du mal
il a fait du mal aux gens on pas
intentionnellement ils ont fait une
erreur stupide et vos soeurs ont connu
un sort tragique
ce n'est pas ce qu'il voulait c'est
arrivé ouais c'est tout exactement c'est
totalement arrêté remords du moins
jusqu'à votre nuit de pure torture voilà
on va le faire on va le faire fou
jusqu'au bout ce n'était qu'un jeu
rien qu'un jeu mais c'est un jeu qui
vous a confronté à l'une de vos plus
grandes rock you choir la solitude
et oui et oui josh [ __ ] web avant la
zone des messages de plus c'est juste
ouf
j'aurais jamais j'aurais jamais deviné
que en fait le tueur n'était pas un
humain mais c'étaient des créatures de
l'espace qui ont une peau comme ça des
dents comme ça ainsi si comme un rat
débat on va n'hésitez pas aimé l'épisode
ça vous a plu on se retrouve très
bientôt pour le prochain qui sera le
dernier on fera des deux derniers
chapitres en une seule vidéo ça va être
plein d'émotions de suspense de dessus
voilà aux autres très vite d'un prochain
épisode ce sera samedi je vous dis à
samedi portez vous bien sûr tout le
monde bis
[Musique]